former New York Giants quarterback out
of Duke the first overall pick in the
1992 supplemental draft Dave Brown how
are you Dave
thank you thank thank you for thank you
for being here cuz obviously your name
comes up a lot it has come up a lot more
often than not since Daniels drafted my
kids were on Twitter and they're like
dad you're trending on Twitter I'm like
no do not read that right now well I
mean see you were trending on Twitter
because Daniel Jones was selected out of
Duke which you were as well back in 1992
so that actually happened I was too I
was doing the draft I did not know that
you were trending on Twitter that soon
enough yeah uh you know interesting
comments on Twitter when that happened
it's interesting I know for sure and I
want to get into that but I want to
start with your journey first so you
you're from New Jersey
you're from the New Jersey area and then
you went to Duke yes how did you get
there you know I got I was pretty highly
recruited and I went to go visit Duke
and Spurrier was there and really all it
was was he put on a film of one of their
games I think quarterback had six
touchdown passes their throne reverses
and flea flickers and just sort of
knowing the system they were gonna be in
and then also just it's a great
institution so I sure if I never played
it down I get a great degree so uh
so I really went to that no they only
visit and I know Michigan is one of
schools I was considering the kid didn't
didn't even go on the trip they're not
even going there now so that was
probably Gary Moeller at the time that
was there oh I mean I wasn't Bo it
wasn't it was it's probably already turn
the page to Gary Moeller interesting so
you you go and you're your visit to Duke
was Steve Spurrier the old Ball Coach
just pop and film on yeah how did he how
did he influence your your time there at
Duke I mean he so in high school I
didn't only throw in a lot I threw it
probably eight or nine times a game I
ran the option believe it or not right
um but I think his you know his just
ability to take this and a rough-edged
quarterback and really refine him and
really refine my my throwing technique
and doing things like that or what
really made it really effective for me I
think the greatest thing did though was
like taught us how to play quarterback
he was pretty rough on all of us and so
I mean practices were very hard wait a
min
and felt like the games would be easy
because just every single throw was
under scrutiny and every rout was on her
scrutiny and so it became a you know
trial by fire during practice so going
out and actually being an ACC
competition was a was a relief really it
really honestly it really was and every
quarterback that played for him will say
the same thing
games were just easy compared to
practices could practice that were just
brutal and a lot of things we were asked
to do was change the play the line of
scrimmage every play had a word and we
could audible eyes and if we didn't we
were wrong and so in practice he wasn't
you know different looks at you anything
if you didn't make the right check he
would go crazy and yeah so when he got
in the games it was great because you
kind of knew exactly what you're
supposed to do and became kinda like a
video game you sort of knew you know
exactly what you were doing at all time
right so then eventually he leaves you
go you leave Duke and if you look at the
1993 NFL Draft that Drew Bledsoe was at
the top Rick Myer and then a garrison
Hearst and then eventually the Saints
draft really Willie Roaf eighth overall
and then the Giants are there and it
says the New York Giants forfeited their
1993 first-round pick after selecting
Dave Brown in the 1992 supplemental
draft how did you so that was a crazy
story and it's one I really haven't told
very often but so I'm going through
spring practice my technically my senior
year but I'm a fifth year to come back
for so that's what I was preparing for
but only had two classes left I was for
saving at two classes for my for my
fifth year yes my parents call me the
night before the spring game and said we
want to come down and talk to you and
I'm thinking you know God why are they
coming down for a spring game who really
cares at this point and they sat me down
and said listen we've been having quite
discussions with the New York Giants Tom
moisture the the player personnel
director and others have a meeting in
these hotel rooms these clandestine
meetings to say we like the team we have
we have phil simms Nahas tellers
quarterbacks that then the ford forecast
for quarterback ratings was coming out
and Bledsoe was the number one overall
and Rick Meyer and I were sort of the
next two quarterbacks and the Giants
liked me better than Rick at that time
but they knew as the draft came out the
next year their team was still pretty
good made Lawrence Taylor and Phil a
bunch of guys they knew that I would not
be around potentially for their draft
pick
so they basically said if I were to
leave school early they would guarantee
that they were draft me in the first
round so it's amazing how your life
changes you know you're very happy in
college and then the next day you hear
this news and you go out there and you
realize like what am I doing here this
is crazy
so hold on I'm gonna follow up here so
you're getting ready for your fifth year
at Duke your folks say hey Dave we're
coming down we wanted to see this they
sit you down and say unbeknownst to you
we have been meeting for four months
they were meeting with the giant yeah
front office staff to say hey if you
leave early we'll take you in the
Supplemental Draft and because we don't
think that we can get him in next year's
draft we're picking him yep so what's
amazing is then I had to hold my own for
a mini combines down at Duke so I
couldn't lead on that this was happening
so I invited all the teams that come
down and I you know had a pretty good
workout your own like pro days yeah I
own protein did Dave Brown rodea on all
teams work on all teams came down except
for the Giants which you know my mom's
freaking out saying this this better be
right you know they'd better not you
know turn their back on me so you know
back then Belichick was coaching the
Browns Sam why she was coaching the
Buccaneers so they then they had private
workouts with me so Sam why she flipped
New Jersey to Westfield where I live and
I had my brother as a receiver and my my
best friend came out and thrown routes
to them and Sam Wyche takes at the lunch
the next week Bill Belichick flies up
and takes me to Madison High School in
New Jersey and gets a bunch of high
school receivers there and I was thrown
to them so it's kind of a long process
in July this happens so it's draft day I
think it was July 13th or something like
that and the way it works is every team
just puts a vote in essentially saying
with when I have that we might pick us
up I'll take him in the second round of
the fifth round of the first round right
so the the the Tampa Bay Bucs of the
first pick of the draft Sam wife says we
don't wanna take him in the first pick
but we want him first first pick in the
second round few teams then pass pass
pass the Cleveland Browns have I think
it was the 13th pick and they say we
want him in the first round and then the
Giants at the 14th pick so my agent said
what do you want
do and sort of you know that wasn't the
deal I want to go play for my hometown
team one puts the Giants so we did that
you know what agents do a good job of
sort of scared them by saying I want X M
on a dollar is some crazy amount I was
way off market and then they rescinded
their offer and then the Giants of the
next pick the Giants took me okay yeah
pretty crazy so with the Browns and
Belichick you know and everything going
on at the time was probably if just off
the top of my head the whole Bernie
co-star Vinny Testaverde right you could
have been the quarterback of the
Cleveland Browns had you not wanted to
go courage so even though the Giants
were trying to or did attempt to game
the system yeah got you to leave yeah
Duke put it backfired you could have
been Bella checks quarterback in
Cleveland two years before aren't Modell
pulls the plug and instead you gamed the
system towards the end to get to the
Giants who backed off to put no finger
prints on whatever they were cooking up
with your parents correct it's good
story right Wow
and that's how you got to the gents yeah
so it's hard I mean I left Duke I mean I
still had great friends there the team I
went through all spring practice I
caught up I really left them hanging out
that's one of my regrets in life maybe I
shouldn't have done that but you know
when you have a an offer to be a
first-round draft pick of your hometown
team it's really harder to pass that up
sure and that's what George Young had
said when everyone was kind of like why
are you using a pick it's in the middle
of what July right yeah right why are
you using a first-round draft pick in
the middle of July on a Duke quarterback
when you've got Sims in Hostetler and we
don't have a first-round pick next year
and with all you know who's Dave Bryan
right so I was the first run pick for
the next year that's why we sit around
yeah right yeah that's why they there
they didn't have one the next year
correct
so all that pressure did do you think
you know your career would have been
different had you not been that way
always look at that and it'll be
interesting if I have I let it play out
you know if I want the Cleveland
Belichick briga coach worked out right
but again I think you know I for what I
want to do at that time
quarterback New York Giants is well
highest things you can ever achieve in
life I mean being in the public eye in
New York being from New Jersey it was
just it was a great experience Dave
Brown here on the Rich Eisen show so
then you get to the Giants ray Hanley's
your coach right Sims and Hostetler are
in the locker room correct were you
welcomed I mean well how are you welcome
just because Ken crane was there as well
and I sort of felt like you know Sims in
a hostile at a time you know we're going
through a little bit of an issue because
Ray Hanley had promised hostile of a
starting job in pre-season and then
hostile got nicked up during preseason
and Phil actually played very well so
Phil was named a starter on opening day
and I mean the quarterback room sort of
blew up at that time you know Hostetler
left Phil was upset that hustler left so
then he left and it's Kent Graham and I
I'd been there for three days and Jim
fossil was our quarterback coach and he
said listen I don't know what's gonna
happen here but one of you guys might be
the starting quarterback this week I
don't know any plays right but then they
they sort of came back and Phil's a
starter and the year was just you know
Phil got hurt against the LA Raiders out
here hostile got hurt
Hank RAM and I then played against the
Cowboys when I say Thanksgiving Day okay
so your first game in the NFL we just
walked through how you were born into
the NL you were baptized in the NFL how
blitz under fire by the Dallas Cowboys
on Thanksgiving Thanksgiving Day I mean
that was me think about the only Cowboys
in Texas Stadium with the triplets
triplets but the defense at the time was
Haley made everyone right yeah I mean
the whole eight defensive linemen they
would just roll and it was they were on
stop were you ready no no again I
because I got there late in training
camp no I didn't have the OTAs I didn't
have training camp and by the time the
season starts you know the third string
quarterback is getting zero reps so for
me it was just you know I had to kind of
learn on the side I remember going Jim
fossils house for dinner some nights and
sort of learning the playbook with him
and so by the time I got to week 10 or
whatever it was I kind of knew what I
was doing but not not that any level be
successful what was the final score that
day and Thanksgiving Day yeah 32 3 yeah
I think we scored I think we scored an
opening drive - oh you got that it was
three nothing yeah it was three hours
all down
well actually there's nine three they
opened with three field goals
Matt bar had a 42 yarder before the half
there you go okay so then you how did
you get this starting job there
essentially yeah so then the next year
Phil's the starting quarterback we had
Dan Reeves as our coach right was the
backup Phil played great we made the
playoffs he sort of injured himself in
the last playoff game against the 49ers
we got blown out I think Ricky Watters
at five touchdowns and in the game and
then the offseason came so I mean you're
three now of my career again a
first-round draft pick the pressure is
sort of Honda you know a moves got me
hazers I mean it feels 38 years old
right he just he had a great season but
he had an injured shoulder and it was
either May or June and I got a phone
call from a PR person the Giants I said
listen Phil Simms had just been released
his press conference is at 3:00 and
yours is it for talk about I'm 23 years
old the time like okay like it's time to
go and I drove in there it was pretty I
mean filling our very good friends and
it was pretty amazing that the way it
worked out I was walking in the building
he was walking out and you know New York
media there was a hundred people in
there cameras everywhere
I started hoping I wouldn't see him but
I'm glad it actually happened this way
he was walking out and I passed him and
just leaned over my ear and whispered so
a little bit nervous now
and they just walked out it was like it
was such like a great like passing the
torch at the time and so how did you
handle it I mean with uh-huh
yes again we're now beginning to
approach Dave Brown here on the richezza
show we're now beginning to broach what
Daniel Jones might be experiencing here
so how did you handle all of a sudden
the 100 cameras interface saying it's
now time for you to win football games
because you're a first-round choice out
of Duke replacing a Super Bowl champion
albeit not release but benched you well
how are you hand how did you yes so I
start to compete no can't quran' was
still there we did feel the guys that
were there so and Dan Reeves was the
coach and it was you know it was kind of
all focus was it was on that I had to I
had to prove myself and certainly being
a first-round draft pick he's where I
get the benefit of
but I did have a really strong preseason
and we played our third preseason game
in Berlin against the Chargers and I was
named a starter then and then you name
the starter in Germany in Germany in
Berlin okay but then you think about so
I started my first week was against the
Eagles at home we won that game second
game we play at Arizona against the
ladies buddy Ryan's home opener
in Arizona 80,000 people desert swarm
they call themselves worse we won that
game and then the next game we played
the Redskins and beat them so I'm a new
quarterback I'm three know going in the
bye week I'm like I'm the king of New
York this isn't the greatest job in the
world right and then coming back from
bye week then sort of reality hit me
lost lost six games in a row so we were
three and six I got benched they put in
King cram we didn't win that game then I
came back and won our next seven games
in a row so we went three and we went
our six yeah we went three no oh no 700
and seven one when it out we finished
here nine and seven we missed the
playoffs by it's a famous play I think
in in Green Bay Packer history Brett
Favre scrambled with no time left and
leapt into the end zone against the
Falcons there's kind of bonehead play if
he if he we can stop the game was over
right but Brett being Brett jumps in
right wind so they they go over us and
we had to beat the Cowboys the last game
of year to actually qualify so you're in
the 97 it was you know up and down but
all in all it was a successful campaign
so I was nine and six as a starter my my
first year but then your next two years
not not so much do you think the New
York media how did you out of town Dave
is it now I mean listen I I didn't have
a great career I mean I think it was
probably honestly was probably the right
thing to do at that time to move on I
mean I think the one reason we talked
about you know affairs and I don't do a
lot of these interviews I'm not like
because there's you know there's enough
ex-athletes and sort of promote
themselves and try to justify their
careers and you know you know I kind of
know what I am and know what I did and I
don't feel like I need to justify in my
existence I thought you know I enjoyed
myself had a great time
you know did everything I tried tried to
achieve and you know I didn't win a
Super Bowl didn't make playoffs a lot
but I still enjoyed myself so yeah I
mean obviously you've got a very
successful career in the finance world
right now managing director of molas &
Company Dave Brown here on the Rich
Eisen show so what would what would you
say was the reason why perhaps you did
not realize what the Giants had hoped
yeah for you well I think so after we
were nine in seven they began to sort of
purge the old yield guard so our
offensive line was released William
Roberts he's got a jumbo le with the
Jets with a lot of guys and they were
sort of trick transitioning a team now
from the Super Bowl champion team that's
sort of the newer team and so one of the
things that that I had to do as in my
next year starting was cut down my
interceptions that was like the number
one thing I to take care of so I
actually did I threw I threw a let me
think about this now and the day and age
of all his passing I threw 11 touchdown
passes and 10 interceptions the next
year which was you know we ran the ball
so much 11 touchdowns was you know
nothing sure guys doing that almost in
two weeks right but cutting that
interception so I think at the time was
when the lowest percentages for
interceptions in Giants history so in
that regard I achieved that goal but we
were you know we weren't a very good
team I think we were 5 and 11 or
something like that something offseason
the coaches said ok now we got to get
more touchdowns and reducing receptions
but in a running offense it's really
hard I always equate it you might Duke
if you think about in Spurrier's offense
you know I had the keys to everything I
could change deploy at any time to find
out to get to a better play in New York
and Revis system and Reeves is a great
coach it's just he would not allow the
quarterbacks to make any changes so
there'd be nine guys and this gap over
here and we're running play here
I had no ability to change that ok and
we very frustrating is a guy coming from
the Spurrier system where I could change
it to everything well and that's the
rain just hamstrung in that system but
Dave that's also the reason why I'm sure
Belichick was knocking on your door in
in in the Supplemental Draft that
there's a kid that has such a grasp of a
system like Spurrier's what was being
run at Duke after you and have the neck
up ability to read a defense pre-snap
and change into it I mean that's such a
rare it in so and I would also say too
that you know I thought Phil Simms
was a master at you know he'd heat up a
boring game it was 17 a 23 for 200 yards
two touchdowns and he sort of managed
the game very well and I was equated to
you know a Duke you could throw you know
a few go routes to set up a curl route
or a comeback round something shorter I
was I quitted to like a pitcher on an O
and to count throwing a waste pitch to
set up the strikeout short hitch with
the Giants in that system there were no
waste pitches it was third and 10 third
and eight and you didn't get a lot of
nice easy free throws every throw was
sort of had to be completed to keep the
chains moving and again I don't think I
adjusted very well of that system I
wanted to be more free and open and
throw the ball and and just you know
have more fun doing it well in the few
minutes we have left with you Dave Brown
let's get let's get to the here and now
what advice do you have for your fellow
Dukie and Daniel James listen he's off
to a great start I mean he had a great
preseason I think you know I sort of
think what happened last week against
the bills with Josh Allen his ability to
make plays outside of the pocket you
know Daniel Jones runs a four six forty
he's big he's strong he's a little bit
like Josh al in that regard and I think
if you think about Shermer and the
coaching staff they're watching Josh
Allen run around make plays I think that
time they probably said you know what
Eli is had a great career the team is
gonna be struggling a little bit this
year let's get a guy is more athletic
back there and seed he can make plays I
think that was probably one of the
reasons they made that move this week
well and then there's the issue of of
the reception and again the reception
you you received in is the reason why I
think you were trending on that draft
night day for sure because Chris can
attest to this Chris Brockman over there
we did we were doing our show from
Nashville from the draft the day after I
have not and I've done 16 drafts now I
it's tough to remember a draft choice
more vilified more vilified than Daniel
Jones being selected by the Giants at
six instead of say Haskins or waiting
til they had more draft choices in the
first round to go get him and the
general manager essentially saying hey
we we we knew others wanted them and to
I fell in love with him after three
snaps at the Senior Bowl and people are
like what yeah so so how do you forget I
mean listen he's had his preseason was
again this preseason he looked in
complete control of the offense he was
very smart guy I think the thing with
him that you know when I watched him at
Duke and I watched him a lot if there
was one concern I had with him it was I
felt like he he was a little bit late
with his throws and it might be because
the athletes he was throwing too maybe
weren't his couldn't get open as much as
the guys get thrown to now and that was
my one big concern is him just throwing
a little bit late at times I'll tell you
I mean I've not seen that in the Giants
so far and a preseason games he
anticipated well he threw a great ball I
mean I think he's gonna be a really good
quarterback and I mean I'm rooting for
him obviously but I sure I think they I
think they may have found every year
there's fort of the diamond in the rough
that they found and I think this could
be the guy so the the reception that he
received I mean do you have any advice
for him ah yes I've sent some emails
I've gone back and forth him and his
father as well and you know on draft
night I sent a note to his father and I
said you know don't don't judge the
reception on him I said some of it is
just a hangover from maybe my career
there that the whole it's the Duke
connection and things like that I go
listen just you know block that out just
keep your head down do your job and and
I know it'll work out for you so it's I
feel like it's a little bit unfair
because again the giant fan has the
history of the do quarterback being
there that didn't work out so well so
it's he's getting a lump into that Dave
there's no question yeah that has
happened yeah and that is something that
is working against him for sure as he
also by the way one touchdown pass you
know how it's gonna work
hooray oh yeah Dave gentlemen now all
the sudden they're like let's just put
him in I mean so it's ya know I know
that you can't you can't spell fanatic
without fans so um so again you are
you're in contact with yeah do you speak
with him yeah I don't speak to him we've
exchanged some emails yeah okay and are
they are they is similar to him speaking
in front of a microphone he sounds just
like Eli it's unbelievable like Eli as
well so it's uh it's funny well and
again you know it's gonna help him to
you think that he lost their right and
you know and you know obviously he's
disappointed and he's not happy
I feel ill I is one of those
professionals that's gonna be fun it
weird for Eli though I mean obviously
he's gonna be great for for Daniel and
mentoring and everything else but you
know if you're a lie and you've been
taken out yeah do you want to go back in
now you know if he gets hurt you know
you've already started givin up on me
I'm sort of lame-duck quarterback I mean
I I was actually shocked to hear anyone
in your being in the show yes he's
waived his trade clause I mean if he
hasn't even yet he won't do that yet
yeah you consider do you think I mean
there are a lot of teams out there in
the quarterbacks right now that our good
teams you you'd think that he would want
to maybe prove the giant fans and the
generalization wrong and say okay trade
me to the Steeler to trade me to you
know Jacksonville where Coughlin is I
think that'd be a great thing for him
but you're also a guy that still lives
in the state of New Jersey maybe he
likes living there yeah honestly he's
got four kids right I mean I don't know
but it's like he's moving you know he's
there for three months four months
that's true it's like a business trip
it's true speaking of which how's your
business Dave it's good yeah it's very
good you want to throw it out yes I run
within moles and company there's a
private funds group which essentially I
go out and raise money from institutions
for guys essentially who buy and sell
companies so I we provide in the capital
do so it's it's called private equity
okay and we've good business good team
or about 22 people but our firm is it's
growing we're about 19 offices globally
and it's a good group of people are the
marriage of the tissues a client no
that's a good I should call them come on
they should be throw it out there hey
Dave I really appreciate you take your
time strolling down memory lane cuz I
again I know you don't do it a lot so at
all so I really I really appreciate that
right to be here you got it that's Dave
Brown managing director of Mullis &
Company wow what a story can do 30 for
30 on the last 20 minutes right here on
the Rich Eisen show when we come back
eight four four 204 rich great poll
question and we will review the fantasy
draft I mean the fantasy trade that we
have put and had thrown in front of us
for Patrick mahomes and we are thinking
about it eight four four two oh four
rich number to dial back with that in a
second
four more of the Rich Eisen showtune -
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV for free
on BR live or download the Rich Eisen
show app